Welcome back to human emotion.
I want to start out with a quote that
William James said when he was discussing
how central the physical body
is to our experience of emotion.
He said,
no shade of emotion should be without
a bodily reverberation and hear.
What he was really emphasizing is that
our physiological responses are heart
racing or our palm sweating,
our knees shaking.
All of these things are really part and
parcel of what make an emotion in the
first place.
And we talked about this actually very
early in the course and we were sort of
reviewing our theories
of emotion through time.
So we began the first part of the chorus
by discussing theory by William James,
which was referred to as
the physiological approach.
And here he argued that feelings and
emotions are actually secondary to
physiological phenomena.
In another words, um,
he took the position eat to even argue
that the essence of what an emotion is is
the physiological response.
And so this is what I want to turn to
today to really question what role does
physiology play an emotion?
Our emotions?
Nothing without our heart racing
and our palms sweating or are,
is part of what makes our emotions
physiology. And if so, in what way?
So today what I want to
turn to is our lecture,
which will really focus on how we can
learn about our emotions by studying our
bodily sensations using the rigorous
scientific tools of aspect of science.
So today let's look at our
heart and ask ourselves,
is our heart really a
window into our feelings?
So today we're going to start our first
part of a three series overview into
what's called psychophysiology. Um, here,
what we're going to be doing is looking
at emotions through the window of bodily
responses and ask ourselves whether our
blood and sweat are really a clue into
our feelings, our tears, and our fears.
So let's get started with an
introduction to psychophysiology.
So today what we're going to do
is start with our roadmap here.
We'll start by first asking ourselves,
well,
what is psychophysiology
in the first place? Second,
we'll go over some basic principles of
how you measure physiological responses.
As a first kind of first step into
thinking about how we can study emotions.
We need to first understand how we measure
physiological sensations in the body.
Then we'll move on to our,
um,
take home questions followed by our
expert interview today with one of the
renowned figures in the field
of psychophysiology sled.
Start here by looking at this question
about what is psychophysiology.
So here you can see an article and this,
this is an old newspaper article,
but I really love it because what it says
at the top here is electric meter test,
skin to gauge emotion.
And what I think is important to take
away from this article is that even long
ago, many of us thought that, you know,
there was some way in which
we can measure, you know, uh,
electrical signals in the body,
sweating from the fingertips
as a way to study emotion. Now,
back then they were using something
called galvanic skin response,
which is also been used as part of the
lie detector. Uh, you know, uh, equipment.
But we know today that there's much
more to gauging emotion through
physiological sensations than just
the amount of sweat on our hands.
So where have we come since then?
Well,
here we've come along ways
and as part of this journey,
we've really founded a field
called psychophysiology.
And so you may wonder, well,
what is psychophysiology in the first
place? And when I want to do here,
share with you a few different
definitions of how various, you know,
authoritative figures in the field have
defined the field of psychophysiology.
So you'll see here, one definition
of psychophysiology is the science,
which concerns physiological activities,
which underlie or relate
to psychic events.
And by psychic they mean
psychological, um, you know,
not some sort of reading into
a crystal globe here. Um,
then we also see a definition here by
Casio and colleagues where they defined
psychophysiology as the
scientific study of social,
psychological and behavioral phenomena
as related to and revealed through
physiological principles,
any events in functional organisms.
And then finally we see Alan
and colleagues talk about
psychophysiology has the
use of a particular set of physiologically
based dependent or independent
variables to gain insights into
psychological questions. Now,
as important as it is to think
about what psychophysiology is,
which is a measurement of different
physiological sensations that may map onto
important psychologically
relevant processes like emotion.
We also want to be very clear
of what psychophysiology is not.
So psychophysiology is not the same as
what's called physiological psychology.
I know it sounds very similar,
but it's actually quite different.
So physiological psychology is actually
a subdivision of biological psychology
that studies neuromechanisms of behavior
through direct manipulation of the
actual neural tissue in the brain
in these controlled experiments.
Psychophysics psychophysiology is
also not behavioral neuroscience,
so behavioral neuroscience by contrast,
as you can see here is the scientific
study of the central neural basis of
behavior and mental states.
So one important way in which
it's differentiated from
physiological psychology
and behavioral neuroscience is it doesn't
have this exclusive focus on neural
tissue or neural basis of behavior.
It's much broader thinking about
the physiological system as a whole.
And in particular a lot
of psychophysiology we'll
focus on the peripheral
nervous system.
So things like your heart rate,
your blood pressure as opposed to more
specifically focusing on the central
nervous system, which includes
measures of neural activity.
So we're going to now delve
into psychophysiology, um,
by thinking about the pros and cons.
So what can we gain from psychophysiology
as budding emotion researchers and
what might be some of the limitations?
So if we think about the
pros of psychophysiology,
there's a few we can get around social
desirability, which is this pressure.
People have to respond in a certain
way when they're in a study,
especially during questionnaire studies.
Um,
they feel like there's a certain right
answer that they should endorse on a
given measure.
The other pros of psychophysiology is
that it helps provide information about,
um,
psychological processes.
So about emotion that's relatively
outside of conscious awareness,
meaning that it can be pretty difficult
to consciously manipulate your,
your blood pressure or the amount that
you're sweating from the palms of your
hands.
So in this way,
psychophysiology really lets you get
outside of conscious awareness and sort of
get some of the automatic processes
that are happening when we experience an
emotion. And then finally, um,
psychophysiology enables you to identify
how mental states such as feeling
fearful or feeling happy are
related to physical health.
So you can look at things like
we've been talking about, you know,
cardiovascular functioning, um, you
know, things like blood pressure,
we'll talk about things like
cardiac impedance, um, later on.
And we can this way also link emotion
as a psychological process to physical
health outcomes. So these are some of
the advantages of the psychophysiology,
but like every tool and every field,
there's also limitations.
So some of the limitations are what we
think of as cons of psychophysiology are
as follows. So the methods are
sometimes difficult and expensive.
So they're difficult insofar as you're
hooking people up with a lot of different
sensors.
Some of them can be uncomfortable for
people and many of them limit the kind of
mobility people have. They're sitting
in a chair, relatively static,
and they can't really move around.
And they're actually quite expensive.
So if you're buying some of this
equipment for your laboratory,
you can easily spend up in the tens of
thousands of dollars just getting the
equipment there in the first
place to run your study.
And there's some controversy on exactly
what we as emotion researchers can
actually infer from
the psychophysiological
measures. So for example,
as you see here, if you have a higher
heart rate, what does that mean?
Does that mean that you're angry?
Could it mean that you're sad or
is it just a sign of movement? Um,
or maybe someone you know recently
came into your lab after, you know,
taking a jog in their heart is
still pumping relatively quickly.
So it can be hard to know exactly what
you take away just from psychophysiology
alone. So let's think about what
psychophysiology is, what it's not,
and the pros and cons as
we now delve into this.
An overview of the autonomic
nervous system. So again,
we know we have the nervous system here.
Okay.
And the nervous system
has two central branches.
So you have the central nervous system,
which includes your brain and spinal
cord and the peripheral nervous system,
which includes all other nerves.
And as I have highlighted here,
this is the system that we're going to
be focusing on the peripheral nervous
system. This is where psychophysiology
really concentrate its efforts.
And in particular if we look into
the peripheral nervous system,
we see that it's also broken
up into two branches itself.
So you have the autonomic nervous system
or the ans which monitors sort of your
internal world that kind of carries
out these automatic processes.
And this is contracted with
the somatic nervous system,
which is more about
monitoring the external world,
carrying out more voluntary processes.
And here psychophysiology again really
focuses on these automatic processes that
are relatively outside of conscious
awareness through the autonomic nervous
system and importantly a psychophysiology.
That's what we're really measuring.
Then, um, his activity in these two
branches of the autonomic nervous system.
So you have your
sympathetic nervous system,
which is really this fight or flight
system that really is geared towards
facilitating energy expenditure as
compared with the parasympathetic nervous
system,
which is really this rest and digest or
people call it 10 number friend system.
That's really about facilitating
recovery in energy storage.
So today we're going to be talking about
different ways you can measure activity
in the sympathetic and
parasympathetic nervous system
as highlighted there.
Now when we get into these two branches
of the autonomic nervous system,
the sympathetic neurosystem and
parasympathetics or SNS and pns, um,
we can see a few things here. So
here, if we look into the SNS, again,
this is our fight or flight system. It's
very excitatory. What it's focused on, uh,
essentially is I'm looking at things
like the release of catecholamines.
So epinephrine or norepinephrine
from the adrenal Medulla.
So what it's a sort of
seen as overseeing or um,
you know, directly facilitating
is things like, uh,
increases in heart rate and blood
pressure, slowing your digestion,
dilating your pupils.
Essentially what we're seeing is,
as you can see here on the graph,
the sympathetic nervous system is really
about mobilizing your body to either
fight or flight. So when there's
a potential danger or threat,
it's getting your body ready to expend
energy and potentially run away or um,
you know, confront a particular rival. Um,
so really what's happening is it's
shutting down a lot of automatic processes
like digestion and really
getting your body mobilized.
Now this is in stark contrast with the
parasympathetic nervous system or pns,
which is focused on this
sort of rest and digest.
So here what we're seeing is the
facilitation of energy storage.
We see a decrease in heart
rate and blood pressure.
We see digestion becoming activated
cause you're sort of at ease.
You can now tend to,
I'm digesting food material.
You see contraction of the
pupils and really interestingly,
and what we'll talk about further
on his activity of the Vegas nerve,
that many people are now seeing as a
really important of emotion regulation as
well as positive emotionality. So
we'll return to that later. Um,
importantly,
what you want to know when it comes
to these two branches of the autonomic
nervous system is that they
have different profiles.
So there they can sort
of act independently or
orthogonally of one another.
Um, so I just want to put this here for
didactic purposes just so you know that
there's kind of four different profiles
you can have at any given time.
And you can be high in one
branch of the nervous system.
So high in sympathetic activation and
either high and parasympathetic are low in
parasympathetic.
Likewise,
you can be high in parasympathetic
activation in either high or low and
sympathetic.
So these are sort of operating in
parallel with somewhat competing goals.
And so they have this sort of,
you know,
push and pull relationship
with one another. Um,
that's constantly going on all the time.
So you can have profiles here that are
called reciprocal sympathetic activation.
So the stress response co activation,
which is engagement and stress,
which is engaging your regulatory
systems co inhibition or this reciprocal
parasympathetic activation.
So this is what we think of as these
ans interaction profiles. Again,
the ways these two different branches
of the audit anomic nervous system can
interact with one another.
And what's really important as we get
started sort of delving into the realm of
psychophysiology has to be really
clear on important terminology here.
So let's imagine you
have an experiment here.
So you have your control group and
white and some comparison group in blue.
You have there, um, you know,
physiological response of a
given measure at baseline.
And you also have it in response to an
emotional provocation watching a film
recalling an emotional memory.
And there's two terms I want
to be really clear about.
So the first is what's called
physiological reactivity.
So reactivity is really looking
at a change from baseline.
So how much does the control group in
white increase when they're going from
their baseline to the emotion provocation.
Likewise with the blue group here to here.
So to compute reactivity,
what you really want to do is compute a
change or what's called different score
between this and this as
well as this and this.
So really you're looking at from your
own baseline. When you come into a task,
how much do you either move up or down?
Now this is quite different from
what's referred to as responding.
So responding says,
I don't care about the baseline,
I just want to understand during this
task what the raw responses were.
So put everyone's own
individual baseline aside,
tell me how much responding we saw as
a function of this part of the task.
So again, reactivity takes into
account baseline responding does not.
Okay.
Okay. And we'll move more into
this later on in our lecture.
But I want to remind ourselves, this is
something we saw earlier in class, um,
which is just that, um, you know,
psychophysiology is really important
because it can sort of begin to provide a
map or a profile of the landscape
of different ranging from anger,
fear, sadness to discuss and potentially
even happiness at the bottom.
We'll return to this later in the lecture.
But keep this chart in mind as we start
to go through different methods and
different measurements and think about
how they can actually inform the way in
which our body responds when we're having
different kinds of emotional states.
So with that being said,
I want to now move from
what is psychophysiology
sort of what is the field,
what are the core terms,
what can we learn from it
to sort of getting into how
we measure these responses
in the first place. If you're conducting
a laboratory study, where do you begin?
What tools do you use?
So now we're going to go on to
this component of measurement.
Yeah.
So I want to think about two different
ways when we talk about measurement.
So one kind of measurement is in the lab,
so you're bringing in participants to
your lab and measuring responses while
they're with you.
And we'll talk about this first and
then we'll go to outside of the lab,
sort of how you can measure physiological
responses and people's own daily lives.
So let's start here with inside the lab.
So what I want to walk
through or different equipment
and tools that have been
used to measure physiological
responses in the lab.
So I love this here for
historical purposes.
So this is one of the earliest models
that was used to measure physiological
responses in the lab called
the grasp model seven.
And as you can see at the bottom,
and even had the polygraph paper with a
little impendent sort of wrote out the
signals as the person was going through
the task. Um, we no longer use these.
They're big,
they're cumbersome.
You have to actually use
paper to record your data.
We've now moved to much more digitally
based systems and the two major companies
out there right now are biopack and mine
were and they're both fantastic systems
for measuring physiological
responses in the lab.
You can see they have different
amplifiers that read the signals from the
participant and then display them
digitally on a computer monitor.
Okay.
Um, this is a picture from my lab
using, um, as you can see here,
the mine were based equipment where we
have people come into the lab and you
have a whole row of different
physiological sensors,
sort of like stickers that are adhesive
and they stick to the skin and we attach
them to participants in our
lab as you can see here, um,
to measure their ongoing
physiological responses.
So here's one of my research assistants
in the lab. As you can see on the, uh,
the right hand picture, there's a little
white box with Blue Line around that.
So that's an amplifier.
And the cables that are hooked up to her
feed into that amplifier there to then
produce a signal, um, while she's
doing the task. So playing long,
uh, with a very important task in our
lab, um, singing, twist and shout.
And then while she's doing that,
she's answering questions on the computer,
monitor recording how she's feeling.
And as you can see here,
we monitor her remotely from a control
room and you can see not only her
behavior,
but you can also see her
online physiological responses
there in the monitor and
the different colored channels and looks
something like this. So you're able,
using the system that you can get
people's a wide range of different
physiological responses to hear.
Some of the things you can see are
the electrocardiogram signal in red.
So this is your heart rate.
Um,
so we're able to see this on a second
by second moment while in the lab.
Okay.
Now let's contrast this with
measuring physiology outside the lab.
So what have you actually want to get
people's physiological responses in their
own or actual daily lives?
So one of the tools that we've used in
our lab is what's called the biopack bio
harness.
So this is a method of what is called
ambulatory physiology are really getting
mobile assessments of people's
physiological responses. So here, um,
you take people outside of the lab and
they were this velcro strap that's worn
lightly around the abdomen.
And in the front there's a little data
computer chip here that records things as
you can see,
ranging from heart rate
to skin temperature to
respiratory sinus Arrhythmia,
which we'll talk about later
as a potential correlative
emotion regulation and
positive emotion as well as general
movement in three dimensional space.
So just looking how much people
generally are moving around, um,
and to what extent that might also
relate to their physiological responses.
So not only can you measure
these responses in the lab,
we can also get really
beautiful assessments of them
in people's own daily lives,
which is thought to really increase
ecological validity of your study. Um,
let me just walk you
through a schematic of um,
one of the studies we've done in my lab
using ambulatory physiology monitoring
tools.
So in this study we had participants
who first visited the lab and when they
visited the lab we did a
baseline assessment of their
clinical profile using the
skid as well as getting different
measures of mood symptoms and basic
demographics.
After the lab,
they were oriented to what we called
inexperienced sampling study or ESM,
which we've talked about
earlier in our course.
And we looked at different
methods of measuring emotion.
So for approximately one
week in their own life,
they completed different assessments
at random intervals throughout the day
using a palm pilot, recording what
they were doing, who they were with,
what they were feeling,
and different kinds of
regulation strategies they
use to manage or control their
emotions.
Along with that,
so you can see here is the palm pilot
with the questions we talked about in
terms of an effect context
and regulation strategies.
You can also see our participant here
wearing that, um, ambulatory straps.
So the bio pack bio harness.
So not only are we getting in her daily
life how she's feeling and what she's
doing,
um,
but we're also getting simultaneously
her physiological responses that were
collected during this period.
And then finally you bring people
back into the lab and you collect the
equipment.
So now you have a really elegant
measurement of both how they report their
feeling and their physiological responses,
which again,
as we spoke about at the beginning,
are relatively outside
of conscious awareness.
So, um, go back there really quick.
So what we're going to go
over in the rest of the class,
our next module is going to detail more
precisely about when we look at methods
that are used both inside
the lab and outside the lab.
What precisely are we measuring?
So what separate physiological
channels are we tapping into?
So we're going to spend the next
module going into different measures of
physiological functioning, ranging
from, you know, heart rate to sweat,
to breathing, frequency, skin
temperature, and even blood flow, uh,
in greater detail.
But I just want to give you a roadmap
today of where we'll be going next as we
sort of delve into the world of
psychophysiology. So with that,
I want to conclude with takeaway questions
for our introductory segment today on
psychophysiology.
So the take home questions
today are as follows. So first,
what were the two main branches of the
autonomic nervous system that we talked
about today that are central in the study
of psychophysiology and what function
do each of them serve?
Second,
can you name and describe several basic
emotions and their associated autonomic
profiles? So there was a table we showed
earlier in the lecture today that had,
you know,
five or six distinct emotions and the
different autonomic profiles that would
map onto those emotions.
So you might want to go back,
remind yourself of that particular part
of the lecture and see if you can answer
for yourself this question of can you
describe what the autonomic profiles are
of these basic emotions?
And then finally,
how are psychophysiological measures of
emotion assessed both inside the lab and
outside the laboratory.
So what are the ways that researchers
who want to study physiological responses
look at this in these two
different contexts? And finally,
we'll conclude with our
expert interview for today
and today as part of our experts
and emotion interview series,
we have the honor of speaking
with doctor John Kasey Yotpo. Um,
he's going to speaking to
us about psychophysiology,
both the scope of
psychophysiology and the promise.
It bears for emotion research.
So Dr Casio Opo uses a
variety of psychophysiological
methods in his research,
including Autonomic Neuroendocrin,
Fsri Eeg,
Erp, as well as quantitative genetics. Um,
doctor Kesey Opo is the Tiffany and
Margaret Blake distinguished service
professor at the University of Chicago.
He's the director of the University of
Chicago Center for cognitive and social
neuroscience and the founding director
of the initiative of the office of the
vice president for research and national
laboratories at the University of
Chicago, seen as a pioneer in
the field of social neuroscience.
He's won numerous awards.
These include the scientific impact
award from the Society for Experimental
Social Psychology,
a merit award from the National Institute
of Health and a presidential citation
from the American
psychological association,
the Theoretical Innovation Prize from
the Society for personality and Social
Psychology,
the Isi highly cited
researchers and psychiatry and
the distinguished scientific
contribution award from the
American Psychological Association,
the award for distinguished scientific
contributions to psychophysiology from
the Psych Society for psychophysiological
research and the troll end research
award.
From the National Academy of Sciences.
Dr Casio is also been elected president
of several scientific organizations that
include the association
for Psychological Science,
the Society for personality
and Social Psychology,
the society for psychophysiological
research and the Society for social
neuroscience.
Doctor Cassiopeia is the past editor
of the journal Psychophysiology,
a former associate editor,
a psychological review and
perspectives on psychological science,
and it's currently in an an associate
editor of social neuroscience.
So I'm very honored to now turn to our
experts and emotion interview with Doctor
John Kasey.
Yotpo.
Okay.